Korea reaches the knockout stage after dramatic victory over formidable Portugal.
Until the second half, World Cup's final Group H match was dragging on to a draw.
If the game ends this way, Korea won't be qualified to the next round...
...with its record of two draws and one loss.
However, a miracle happened during the added time.
What seems like a draw ended up a victory with Huang's last-minute goal.
Korea won the game, but their fate was yet to be determined.
In the other Group H match, Uruguay was still leading Ghana 2 to 0.
Everyone waited nervously.
Even the players gathered in the middle of the field to watch the game on their phone.
Korea's fate is now up to Uruguay and Ghana.
If Uruguay were to score another goal,...
...South Korea would be out of the World Cup.
Korea was barely ahead of Uruguay with one win, one draw and one loss.
Both teams were tied on points and goal difference as well.
However, having scored four goals,...
...South Korea was able to make it to the next round.
Finishing in second place in Group H,...
...South Korea is to face Brazil in the next round,...
...the country ranking first in FIFA world rankings...
...and one of the strongest candidates to win the World Cup.
South Korea may fall behind in ranking,...
...but we hope for another miracle nonetheless.